and what's the connection though with
sam macaroni because you guys were
roommates at the time right were you and
sam roommates yeah uh we met through uh
clifton collins jr actor for interviews
oh yeah and uh just became instant
friends you know you gotta love macaroni
he's funny yeah i just knew immediately
how funny and then you met macaroni
through preston absolutely i met
macaroni through preston and matt carney
and i were just thick as thieves right
away we were
we
were we managed to be each other's lower
companions
i think uh
i think i was perhaps the lower
companion because i always made it to
work no matter like
even if we were on a days-long bender i
always made it to work regardless of
what shape i was in macaroni never made
it anyway he's like dude i've got to be
somewhere and i'd be like oh yeah come
on man we're going to go back and and
get more of this or that
never made it and then you guys all did
tv the movie together right i mean that
was the three of your green child
yeah that was that was all me there well
letting macaroni direct i guess damn so
tell me about that you just had kind of
like maybe from doing the sketches with
leno or something you had sketch ideas
and you were like let's let's make a
movie of sketches yeah we had gotten a
gig on national lampoon's pledge this a
paris hilton vehicle
yeah where we played uh her brothers in
a small role and one of the shady
producers from that we hit up to do a
movie and he was like yeah i can get
that one carlos guy he was like yeah i
can get you guys and i ended up getting
like 2.3 million dollars or something
for that movie and i couldn't believe it
yeah i mean there was all kinds of like
messed up stuff going on on the finances
oh yeah just all completely shady
illegal on all sorts of levels
and i remember too like uh by that point
i actually had gotten an agent and like
i presented i was like yeah they're
giving me points on this movie and and
uh the agent was like i'm sorry to tell
you but those
aren't real points
i was like wait like a point's a point
right like well
the definition of a point here is
meaningless
plus it's still like um 1.7 million in
the red
oh yeah wow
yeah i mean that movie had its moments
it was an overall pile of garbage but it
really had some some great moments in it
people when people bring it up it's like
with reverence you know like it's kind
of a cult classic if you saw it
and you were you know the right age at
the right time there well there's
classics and there's tv the movie
they sold the international rights
before we even had the script done for
sure that was how they'd make the money
you know they just people did and you
never saw a dime from it oh huh when we
got sued even though
you guys said personally yeah no we got
suited i can't mention any names of
course but the guy sued us uh wanting a
writing credit on there a guy who we had
helped us right
come help us a
typist oh my god that's the last thing
if it was like we surveyed 100 people
like i would not have said anybody sued
for credit for that
we had to go to court and be deposed in
all this and he ended up winning um
which he won a credit on the writing
credit on national influence tv the
movie and he had to pay had to pay his
attorneys you know for that stuff they
said it must been 75. you can have
stevo's useless points
so he was getting
you win
the
debt that the movie is in
my buddy mick was cutting his hair at
floyd's barber shop and that guy who
sued and the guy started dropping names
out he's a big hollywood writer and mick
goes i need to tell you that
not only did my buddy preston write that
movie he goes i'm in it
the guy was bragging about writing a
movie that he was in it wow
so you're saying that the guy didn't
actually write it no he wrote i think i
did write one bit or something in there
yeah but he really fell apart with the
horrible things he said on those emails
in the deposition just just racist stuff
and stuff it was like wow like when they
start reading that stuff out loud it's
just like that dude is
dead
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]